one thing that you wish either would
come back or at least stick around from
that era Suki starting with you okay
solid balls Joshua
um I would probably say the fashion I
think some of the flat pants okay
everything's got way too skinny okay I'm
gonna be boring and say architecture I
think it was my honest answer that's not
boring that's brilliant
I'm gonna say the music I feel like you
can't quite beat the 70s era for a music
Camilla I would say the hangs like the
Laurel Canyon hangs the music Gatherings
like going to someone's house and like
sitting around and playing music you
know like we could we could do that
sometimes
um I would I would probably have to say
the originality I think everything in
that era was like new and different than
it had ever been and like just like in
every genre of music and art and movies
you know now it feels like everything's
a copy of a copy of a copy you know
that's a great answer